jon voight mort par asphyxie le 25 mai
dernier alors qu'il était arrêté par la
police dans le minnesota cet incident a
fait monter d'un cran la colère contre
les violences policières subie par la
communauté noire aux etats unis un pays
régulièrement secoué par ce genre
d'événement la première affaire
médiatisée remonte à 1965 à los angeles
au mois d'août le quartier noir de watts
est le théâtre d'une semaine d'émeutes
vous dites une émeute j'appelle ça une
révolte sociale
le point de départ c'est l'arrestation
musclée d'un automobiliste qui a viré à
une rixe entre riverains et policiers
les émeutes en réaction à cet incident
or ont occasionné des pillages des
blessés et 31 morts chez les
manifestants
les violences policières sont
récurrentes à l'été 1967 le lan crude se
meurt des émeutes éclatent dans tout le
pays dans des villes où le quotidien des
noirs et fait de chômage de mal-logement
de discriminations en tous genres les
débordements de la police font éclater
la colère de la communauté
ces deux résultats donc années de
frustration de dépravation du risque en
génération
les violences policières se répète et
installe une peur et une haine mutuelle
comme à miami en 1981 là c'est
l'acquittement de policiers accusés de
viol et de meurtre sur des noirs qui a
mis le feu aux poudres l'on ne pouvait
pas brutaliser un chien très longtemps
sans qu'il se met à vous mordent l'autre
sur les affaires de violences policières
prennent une autre tournure dans les
années 90 avec le film amateur certains
abus sont filmées par des témoins comme
ici à los angeles
56 coup de matraque donner un homme
arrêté pour excès de vitesse
l' affaire devient nationale des
personnalités manifeste comme alec
baldwin et kim basinger la pression de
la société ne changera pas l'issue de la
faire les policiers sont acquittés en
1992 provoquant une vague de violences
los angeles a été placée en état
d'urgence
la garde nationale est intervenu pour
calmer les émeutes
des violences policières se répète la
protestation en réaction ne concerne pas
que la communauté noire de
manifestations en émeutes
les slogans deviennent récurrents pas de
justice pas de paix je ne peux pas
respirer les mots prononcés par eric
garner en 2014 avant de mourir plaqué au
sol par un policier
slogan colère émeutes mais aussi pillage
couvre-feu la mort de djordje floyd
catalyse aujourd'hui encore tous les
éléments d'une colère qui dépasse de
loin les états unis
[Applaudissements]